[Music]
did you see uh
like what michael that guy michael rubin
did
so we talked about him a little bit
to be honest i don't entirely understand
what his business fanatics does but i
know that like he's got three different
companies right now one of them was
worth like 50 billion another one's
worth like a billion in other words
worth like five or 10 billion like it's
just like crazy it's like there's
fanatics and there's like three
spin-offs of it yeah exactly so
um i don't have like a ton of uh you
know kind of like research on him or
whatever but basically fanatics itself
is worth
over 10 billion dollars and what
fanatics does is they basically are a
merch company
but for
sports and so what they do is you want
to go buy a steph curry jersey whether
you buy it in the nba shop the warrior
shop or you just google steph curry
jersey and you land on fanatics.com it's
fanatics that's printing and they're
actually like printing the jerseys and
then shipping them out to customers i
get that i just don't understand how can
just like a rookie like a noob i mean
he's not a noob anymore he's been doing
this since he's 21. he's probably 55 now
how can just like a guy come in and just
like muscle like the people who have had
those contracts for 20 decades for 20
years i also had that same exact
question now i know he was kind of like
successful before this i think he had
done a uh it was called a gsi i think
commerce and he sold it to ebay for i
forget exactly how much but he made like
80 or 90 i think and then it didn't work
out at ebay so he bought back some of
the stuff
and he grew that to be big and then he
also spun out a few things so this
company called shoprunner which is quite
popular it's basically like amazon prime
for people who aren't on amazon um he
built that business and a few other
things
and so he started as like a ski shop
when he was 18 i think yeah
yeah exactly ski is sort of a ski
business whatever then became like kind
of apparel logistics so that's gsi
commerce that's sports
again sports commerce he sold that to
ebay i think i don't know if you said
the price 2.4 billion
yeah i think he only walked away with
like 80 which is a lot but uh i i don't
think he i think he gave up a ton of
equity and he was like in his late 30s
at the time and then um
and then yeah i don't know how he got
the contracts but he basically just like
continued licensing i don't think he got
exclusive so i think he got the licenses
to prince print the stuff and then over
time demonstrated that like
they had the best product with the best
delivery with the best quality assurance
and all that stuff and so they ended up
being like we'll just power your shop
right we'll be the we'll be the default
one when you go to like the team's
websites well he also bought a recently
started a cards company that is making
cards and they just and then he was like
you know what let's just buy tops while
we're at it yeah
so i don't understand how he's totally
just kind of brute force his way into
this it seems yeah so he uh exactly so
he bought tops which is kind of like a
pretty interesting
move we've talked about trading cards we
talked about
um you know like this whole thing what
they're what it seems like what they're
gonna do is they're gonna say all right
we got the licenses from the from the
sports teams we can get we can we know
licensing as a business we can get the
licenses for cards as well
we know printing and manufacturing we
can do that with the cards as well but
then also with cards there's like
basically it's the same customer it's
the same fan so if i buy a steph curry
jersey odds are i'm going to be like
somewhat interested in like a steph
curry rookie card and what hit the
reason i want to bring him up was not
because like i had some like deep
insight on his like business plan
although i think it's pretty simple
which is like we have the sports fan as
a customer what do they buy
one of the things that they might buy is
collectibles okay let me go buy tops and
like we'll sell them collectibles but i
thought his approach was smart and one
that people should take which he goes
right now there's like five million
people who collect sports cards and um
so the whole business is like these five
million people
and
nobody has like taken a like big
approach to this it's been this like
hobbyist kind of underground there's
like the charm of it like if you go to
like the annual sports card conference
it's like this yeah in cincinnati that's
like you know these hobbyists bring
their cardboard boxes and like some
special shout out to like you know
kentucky fried chicken for sponsoring
this year's conference or whatever right
and like eric's moms for bringing
cookies yeah exactly
third year running thank you mrs k
um
so they're like you know that's the
conference right now so he's like dude
why is that like that but like sneaker
con is like this [__]
state-of-the-art thing and ces is like
this epic show that's like you know like
cutting it so he's like i'm gonna do all
that in the tr no he's like nobody has
spent a dollar on marketing
collectibles like nobody like it's like
this hobbyist passion industry but
nobody goes out and markets
this thing he's like but people have
done that for sneakers and other things
so i think what he's gonna do one one
smart thing i like this part of the plan
it was
he's basically going to athletes that
like to collect in general he's gonna
like make it known that these
celebrities oh did you know like the
whatever you know like the guy from
billions like the hedge fund manager has
like he's gonna build stuff
he's gonna build like a media company on
top of this a little bit like a media
company or it's a it's going to be a
slick media play and they happen to sell
the cards it's going to be he's going to
make it cool to collect right which is a
smart thing and the reason why again
like okay that's just part of a plan the
one part i really liked is he goes
there's 5 million people who collect
today and what anybody else in the space
has tried to do is try to get as much
take as much as they can from those 5
million my question when we bought tops
was how do we get 50 million or 500
million people to collect
and like that's the only game i want to
play is expanding the total size of this
market from five million people who do
this thing to 50 million people who do
this thing
and i just thought like that's that's a
really powerful mental model for how you
how you build businesses and i've talked
about this before that's the same it's
the same framework
as the the one that the guy from slack
did when he created slack he's like yeah
there's work chat tools and some people
use them but he's like the reality is
eight out of the ten customers that we
talk to companies that we talk to they
don't use a live chat tool they use
email
so he goes his memo was called we don't
sell saddles here right because he's
like if we just go to the existing
people who like horseback riding they
probably already have a saddle we try to
convince them to switch because we got a
better saddle they're kind of familiar
with their ways we're always going to be
in this like tiny niche but
if we sell the dream of horseback riding
and show people how fun it is to go
horseback riding we increase the size of
the overall market and then when they
say oh wow i love this thing but my butt
hurts we'll say great we have a saddle
for you and so that's like just like a
general approach to business that i
think more people should take is
increasing the um
the size of the number of people who
even want your category before saying
pick me
that i think more people should take is
increasing the um
the size of the number of people who
even want your category before saying
pick me
have you i i agree that's a really good
insight and an example of that is have
you seen uh so kevin rose this tech guy
for years kevin rose for some reason
after i forget where he was he was
either i think he was at google leading
like their adventure arm he left and he
became the see i think he became a part
owner and the ceo of this blog called
hodenki yeah i think that's
hodenki
and i remember hearing about that and i
was like what he goes yeah it's a blog
for watches and i was like well yeah
there was a middle step so he created a
studio a lab to incubate ideas and
that's why he was even more crazy he's
like yeah we're creating this like
publication or this thing for watch
collectors and then that got acquired i
think
by either hooding or that was called a
dinky and it got it fired i'm not sure
which one
yeah they sometime this guy other he
already had this blog kevin was
tinkering with it and they became one
and he started working on that and i was
like what the heck man you're like [__]
about buildings yeah aren't you like
yeah
like a blog like what are you thinking
and then i started watching some of
their youtube videos and it was either
kevin or the other guy who started the
the site and he was sitting with john
mayer and they were talking about their
watches and i sat for like 20 minutes
watching this like where john mayer was
like yeah this watch is actually special
for this reason and i was like that's
that's amazing and they had this show on
youtube where they were doing that and
i'm not a watch guy because i don't want
to spend i don't get joy i get more
stressed out of spending 30 thousand
dollars for something on my wrist i kind
of get annoyed with it but i was
watching his stuff and i was like
i want to i want to own this you've
turned me into a a connoisseur or i want
to be connoisseur i want to be part of
this exactly i want to want this i don't
know how yet yes it's like sushi and
wine there's a whole bunch of these
things from like oh i kind of like the
idea of getting into this hobby golf
right like i want to want it
yes and that's how i felt with him and i
could see myself wanting to do this with
cards i am when i was a kid
did you ever collect magic cards not
magic pokemon for me but yeah i did i
did magic and i don't even remember how
to play it and i remember like i was
like just let me look on ebay see how
much some of those are and i was like
i'm just gonna buy some this is this is
fun it'll remind me of my childhood and
i would totally do that with sports
cards even though i don't pay attention
to sports now just remind me of my
childhood i would buy like a
a mark mcguire card or something like
that um
but yeah this is cool i think that's a
really good framework actually
[Music]
you